hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
el 24 de febrero de 2022 la historia de
miles de personas cambió por la guerra
de rusia contra ucrania 60 días después
de la invasión las cifras revelan una
migración masiva en un tiempo récord en
sólo dos meses más de 5 millones de
personas buscaron refugio en otros
países más de un millón retornaron y al
menos el 17 por ciento de la población
ucraniana tuvo que desplazarse
internamente de los que cruzaron
fronteras casi 45 mil llegaron a francia
donde son acogidos así los reciben
voluntarios rusos
un tren procedente de alemania ingresa a
la plataforma y estos voluntarios de la
cruz roja esperan para recibir los
cientos de refugiados ucranianos pasan
diariamente por la estación del este de
parís principalmente mujeres y niños
marcha huyo de los bombardeos en jarquín
espero que todo esto termine y podamos
volver pronto a ucrania sólo quiero
esperar un poco para recuperar fuerzas y
estar dispuesta para ayudar en la
reconstrucción del país
para los refugiados acogidos aquí hay un
giro sorprendente muchos voluntarios
rusos vienen a echar una mano a la cruz
roja que carece de traductores para
asistir y guiar a los recién llegados
anna es de san petersburgo y lleva mucho
tiempo viviendo en francia conoce bien
ucrania ya que viajó hasta allí a menudo
con sus padres con la guerra como
software preso para ser sincera cuando
empezó la guerra lloré durante dos
semanas seguidas lo que me devastó
totalmente al principio fue que estas
ciudades que estaban siendo bombardeadas
destruidas y saqueadas eran de hecho en
las ciudades de mi infancia sentí que
tenía que hacer algo
y los casquillos salvo pocas excepciones
la presencia de los intérpretes rusos es
bien aceptada por los refugiados no no
me molesta no hacemos diferencia entre
los rusos y los otros juzgamos a la
gente por sus cualidades y no por su
nacionalidad aquí nos ayudan no hemos
sufrido discriminación todo está bien la
unión europea creó un estatuto de
protección temporal para los ucranianos
que les permite vivir y trabajar en los
estados miembros de la unión europea por
un año anna quiere ayudar tanto como sea
necesario y mientras pueda sin sanción
soy una mujer de acción estoy
acostumbrada a la acción y cuando hay un
problema hago todo lo que puedo para
resolverlo aquí no puedo resolverlo pero
puedo ayudar un poco
muchos rusos que viven en francia
comparten la angustia de anna y
denuncian públicamente la guerra una
libertad de expresión impensable en
rusia donde el simple uso de la palabra
guerra puede llevarlos a la cárcel
polonia continúa como el mayor país
receptor con casi 3 millones de
refugiados acogidos otros buscaron
oportunidades kilómetros más lejos y
todos intentan recuperar parte de su
vida pese a las secuelas de la guerra
veamos a continuación algunas de sus
historias
la verdad como su única y más sólida
herramienta en esta sala de redacción se
escribe sobre ucrania con la pluma de
refugiados ucranianos cuando estalló la
guerra la publicación alemana catapulta
reclutó a varios comunicadores cuatro de
ellos trabajan desde aquí otros 16
cubren el conflicto desde la zona de
guerra
un trabajo que ante todo debe ser
objetivo
sólo hay que creerle a story cerrar su
propaganda
puedo ver claramente si una historia es
propaganda rusa y algunos periodistas
son demasiado emocionales
y a veces puedo enfrentar cursos
inapropiadas en sus textos
como la opinión de que todos los rusos
son nuestros enemigos
para contratar a estos ucranianos
algunos empleados de la revista
decidieron donar parte de sus salarios
lejos de allí en bucarest estos maestros
ucranianos volvieron a la escuela y sus
alumnos son algunos de sus compatriotas
más pequeños más de 260 niños se
inscribieron a estas lecciones
vespertinas
[Música]
actualmente nuestras clases están
abarrotadas tenemos 8 salones con un
mínimo de 32 niños un máximo de 42 pero
las clases no pueden acoger a tantos así
que todos los días esperamos que no
vengan todos solos
anastasia dice que el proceso para los
menores no ha sido fácil algunas veces
deben enfrentar ataques de pánico
repentinos que quedaron como secuelas de
la guerra
[Música]
pero la vida debe continuar y estas
artistas ucranianas pasaron de la guerra
a un escenario en nueva york' todas las
noches visten trajes con lentejuelas y
lucen amplias sonrisas porque el show
sigue
good show la gente viene y quiere ver un
buen espectáculo un gran espectáculo
y su jefe problema yo canadá
hasta believe y si tienes problemas
debes dejar tus problemas detrás del
escenario e ir y entregarte a la
audiencia
jens a kilómetros de ucrania están
entregadas a su trabajo pero no olvidan
que en casa dejaron a sus familiares de
quienes esperan recibir una llamada que
les confirme el fin de la guerra y
marque la fecha para su eventual retorno
tras dos meses de la guerra contra
ucrania cientos siguen cruzando a diario
las fronteras de su país para huir del
conflicto y una posibilidad de paz
todavía parece lejana hasta que
inmigrantes de france24 los invitamos a
comentar en nuestras redes sociales con
el hashtag migrantes f24 sigan con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]